so you moved to a city and bought a car
now it's time to learn to drive like an
[ __ ] last time I'm driving like a
soul we cover texting at red lights
tailgating and driving 50 miles an hour
in the left lane
this time parking you're in a city so
it's very important to learn how to park
like a tool when looking for a spot
drive as slow as you want no matter how
congested the area is oh look an empty
spot yes there might be room for two
cars here but not the way you drive make
sure you leave plenty of room in between
you and the next bumper not enough room
for a car just enough room for let's say
a golf cart or a dolphin perfect
that'll make someone mad later if you
have a smaller car parking garages are
just the place for you when in a crowded
parking garage make sure you go right to
the front of the spot there it is make
sure it's enough for someone to think
they've finally found an open one aisle
leader crush their dreams don't worry
about validating your ticket you can
probably just use a credit card at the
exit
next time we'll cover never using your
blinker putting your entire family's
lives at risk and making sure you get
the most out of your insurance premium